[Musique]
ouais ya un gars qui vient d'appeler à
docteur tu cherches à chauffeur ça
t'intéresse je ne suis pas docteur en
médecine
je suis musicien je suis sur le point de
partir en tournée dans le sud profond
quel genre d'expérience avec vous
relations publiques verriez-vous un
inconvénient à travailler pour un noir
vous dans le sud
ça va causer des problèmes premiers mois
que tu m'écris c'est trop me dites pas
que ça soit par lausanne et jamais avalé
de poulets frits de toute mon existence
les gens comme vous adore le poulet frit
j'avais une vision de moi plutôt étriqué
de tenir je sais soit main
nous allons fréquenter les personnes les
plus riches du pays alors je pense que
vos manières gagnerait à être plus
raffinés pourquoi vous les voyez menu
parce que vous valez mieux que ça
monsieur vallée longue à c'est un génie
je crois aller manger un bout je préfère
ne pas mettre de gras sur ma tenez où je
veux pas mais de grâce sur ma tenue
monsieur dit que je ne peux patiner ce
bien peur que l'eau
[Musique]
comment il fait pour rester aussi
aimable il faut du courage pour changer
le coeur des joues
qu'est ce que vous faites lettre je peux
voir cher de l'aurès des fois tu me
rappelles la maison vous êtes conscient
que c'est lamentable années note la
distance qui nous sépare des vastes mon
âme tombé amoureux de toi a été la chose
la plus facile du monde s embrassent les
bras c'est comme klaxonner à la fin de
la septième de chostakovitch et c'est
bien parfaitement bien de lui ça fait
des voitures pour ne gagne jamais grâce
à la violence
on ne gagne qu en perdant sa dignité
laissez parler votre goût monsieur je me
la pète qui fait les concerts pour les
rupins si je suis passé noir est aussi
passée blanc alors je suis quoi dites
moi
au nom de peut faire du béton m
[Musique]
et votre musique ce que vous faites vous
et vous qui pourrait faire
que fait-on avec les restes ont fait ça
ramasse lettonie les écureuils le
bouffon toute façon ramasser
[Musique]